whenever I tell people and varsity is 14
they don't understand it at first it's a
I've just seen the computer do nothing
and it's like a whole new world for a
lot of people and here that comes
stompin straight into the base of
Kentucky Robert Morris University in
Chicago has recognized that eSports is
massive with over a hundred thirty
million people tuning in around the
world to watch digital athletes compete
that's why they're the first u.s.
college to offer varsity gaming
scholarships now there's a whole new
kind of jock on campus I'm hisses coal I
go to Morris University and I play on
the varsity team of experts I play
League of Legends the purpose of the
game is destroy the enemy base working
together with the strategy and
communication I'm in a scholarship to
play league of legends my major is
computer networking I really don't know
what I want to do but it sports is
helping me prepare for any job around
computers Ron Morris make it really easy
to play League of Legends and play
sports in general because we have the
eSports arena just by the fact that you
have a room where you can hang with your
team like speak about strategy and know
each other that helps a lot my name is
Kurt Meltzer I'm the executive director
of eSports at Rob Morris University I
really come from a traditional athletic
background
but I've also at that same time always
been in love with video games that's
when it hit me that we could offer
scholarship and get the best League of
Legends players and run it the same way
as we do any of our athletic programs
some of the technical requirements to
have varsity level is definitely as
bandwidth specific we work closely with
our IT department to make sure that we
would have no lag no issues with
Internet I think they doubled our
bandwidth for the University just to
make sure that we're not gonna be
overloading the system and you know
affecting other classrooms
[Music]
vinum varsity sports takes a lot of time
and hard work it's not just you see when
you're computing you have fun it's all
mental
it takes a lot of preparation and a lot
of hard work to be able to perform at
the highest level everything moving
[Music]